De hijo mayor, hay 27 años,
1972.
¿Y en dónde?
En Caracas.
¿Quién es tal?
Primer nieto, querido,
Rike Lerner de Rijs.
¿Dónde está ubicado él en la foto?
Mano derecha.
Al lado, otro nieto de Joey.
Vamos a empezar de una esquina a la otra.
¿Quién está en la esquina derecha?
En la esquina derecha está Joey,
que está casado
con una muchacha muy simpática,
que aquí tiene hija,
y me trajo en el mundo una viñeta,
muy linda,
y estoy muy orgulloso.
Al lado,
112,
está mi querido nieto,
Jonathan Bagamundo.
Muchacho
con poder.
Cuarto.
¿Aquí va Jonathan Gingister?
Mayor.
Rike Lerner.
Un muchacho
que mucho ha hablado conmigo
y jamás me va a olvidar
cuántos me fueron a Stanford
cuando él se graduó.
Era
más grande alegría en la vida
que uno podía tener.
Mi señora, la verdad,
que yo no estaba bien en salud,
era un viaje largo, pesado,
pero dijo, yo tengo a ver.
Él me ofreció
a abuelito,
cuando yo me gradué,
primero voy a entregar a usted
mi título.
Y esta muchacha tremenda
no sacó un título,
no me sacó tres títulos.
Brincó para todos,
no entregó a su mamá, a su papá primero.
Aquí está abuelito, como yo ofrecí a usted.
Imagínese,
esa alegría
que él mantenía esa palabra
y
no quiere mucho hablar,
hay mucho que hablar.
Al lado está
el querido nieto,
el hijo
de Anita Rice,
Leon Rubinstein
Rice.
Bien buen muchacho.
Se graduó a un médico,
yo estuve en graduación.
¿Qué más yo estoy haciendo?
Esbecesa.
Tengo mucho que hablar.
Estoy reservado con palabras.
¿Al lado de Leon quién está?
Al lado de Leon
me parece que está
Samet Rubinstein.
Muchacho
que ha andado con muchachitos
seis años.
Hizo matrimonio civil.
Yo estuve en matrimonio civil.
Y me dijo que matrimonio de él
es 22 de noviembre
y de repente
salió un cambio
de relación,
cambio de la vida
y yo no podía estar
en ese matrimonio.
Me dolió mucho.
Era
un hombre
que era
en mi cabeza
53 mil años
de Jerusalén.
Ya yo tenía pagado mi viaje
y yo estaba entre sí o no.
Entonces
yo me decidí solo
decidir
un sueño
Jerusalén de 2 mil años
tener su propio país
pase sobre todo
histórico.
Dejó mi matrimonio
y me fui para 3 mil años
Israel.
¿Y abajo quién está?
Abajo está un muchachito
que no tiene más
un metro
96 de altura.
Este se llama
Meyer Malkaraj.
Para él tengo muchas palabras
y no quiero decir muchas palabras.
Es un muchacho
un muchacho
que no hay palabras
un muchacho estudioso
con 21 años
se graduó a economista
y él sabe más que un economista
es un querido hijo para sus padres
y un
querido como todos los nietos
por todos los nietos
no hay diferencia
yo quiero todos mucho
con toda mi alma.
Él nunca en mi vida
faltaba una palabra
sin respeto
siempre con respeto.
Ese es mi orgullo
que yo tengo en mi vida.
¿En qué año fue tomada esta foto?
Esta foto fue tomada
no puedo decir en ese momento
porque estoy un poquito borracho
tomo mucho whisky
por decir mi hija
no puedo
ya va, ya va
no parece exacta
créeme que
8 horas
cansa un poquito
hablar
¿En qué ciudad fue tomada esta foto?
En Caracas
¿Qué lugar es este?
Ese lugar, mire
en mi ciudad blodada
mis dos nietos
están adentro
en un parque de Senagoga
que se construyó después de la guerra
de 1939-1945
y esos muchachos
jóvenes
idealistas
que siempre
con ellos
me recargaban
flotados
y fueron con ellos
y regresaron
allá en esta Senagoga
que fue destruido
y
se quedó
el único
museo
10% de Senagoga
imagínate
de mis nietos
¿En qué año fue tomada esta foto?
En 1993
¿Quién está en la foto?
Este señor
Yitzhak Mayaraz
está parado
en la puerta de Senagoga
que allá
era mi Senagoga
allá
rezaron
hasta 6, 7 mil personas
día y noche
el único que se quedó
una puerta pequeña
que yo soy el único
de esta ciudad
que me fui para allá
y en esta ciudad
no contó
de los judíos
una alma
no
era el único
una señora viejita
murió antes
que nosotros
vinimos para allá
¿Y cómo se llamaba esta Senagoga?
Senagoga
Gran
Knesset
Guardada
¿En qué año fue tomada esta foto?
En 1993
¿Y esta foto
quién está en esta foto?
En esta foto está
en esa foto están
dos queridas hijas mías
y un querido
yerno
el nombre de mi yerno
un gran médico Samuel Malka
médico mundial
¿Dónde fue tomada esa foto?
Esa foto fue tomada
fue tomada
en la población jubilska
de Tichna
enfrente
de la propiedad
de la familia Reis
era un gran
molino
cerradero
y aquí estamos
mis dos
hijas queridas
mis tres nietos queridos
y yerno
y ese
Yitzhak Meier Reis
y en esta foto está
con dos
obreros
que se quedaron
de trescientos obreros allá
y en esto
viven todavía
allá
al lado
ese molino
en una casita
allá existían
cincuenta casas
que trabajaban
conmigo
cincuenta familias judías
¿Cómo se llama esta gente?
No, no
no me acuerdo
¿Y en esta foto
quiénes vemos?
¿Quiénes son los que
vemos en esta foto?
¿Qué es?
Esta foto es
también donde está
el molino
a donde rusos
pusieron avisos
rusos
aquí está
mi toda la familia
mis hijas
mis nietos
y mis yernos
y
Yitzhak Meier Reis
¿Y esta era su propiedad?
Todo
legítimo
esto yo compro
con sudor
trabajando
desde los 9 años
hasta 24 años
y 1936
pagado por esto
que el mundo sepa